maybe about six years ago yeah so we
kind of like reconnected through our
mutual friend you Trey farmer maybe like
three or four years ago so it's been a
great ride gonna ride I am I love you
beets yes but I got a picture make
alright thank you guys my name is Joe
bond I'm the first assistant director on
deadly reunion you'll be on your right
monocle grab your left so let's actually
start you here
why'd she start you ahead I know it's
not how you did it before but we'll
start you ahead just for safety sake I'm
doing this guy's real half speed it is
the action we walk in the talking your
width on your width off and then shop
you'll come into tears let's just pick
it up from right there guys and get the
cluster eight in that top end so chunky
this is your one Stuart's have you I'm
sorry right did you let's tell you about
on the left cuz we're gonna end up I
want to clean this up a little bit so
sue you're on the right camera okay
there we go so then we start going
through this stuff like you guys do so
go ahead and go through this stuff how
did you get attached to the project Joe
Joe Karam who is one of the actors he
plays Bobby he was in negotiations to
come on to the project and we'd worked
together once before and he want to make
sure that if he was gonna be a part of
it he wanted to be ran really well from
an on-set perspective and made one of
the conditions that I'd be hired on as
well before he could - he would accept
his involvement so that's how I got on
here we go final round please pictures
up slate it and roll sound and how long
have you been first eighteen
professionally first ad a little over
five years I started I moved down here
from San Francisco I got my Master's up
there and one of my associates who move
down here as well booked a first ad job
for Miley Cyrus for one of her videos he
brought me on as a second ad the
director or the producers liked him but
they don't wanna bring him back so they
brought me back instead and they started
bringing it back over and over again and
recommending me to other producers and
that's kind of the history of everything
that's history of my career I just got
recommended recommended and recommended
and it's kind of spired spiderwebbed out
from there and as a first ad what is
your from the minute you get on set like
what's your responsibility what are you
looking for at all times
no dead time I mean fundamentally you're
trying to get the greatest amount of
quality footage in the can for the
director and the production at any given
time and what usually happens on a lot
of sets especially you don't have a
strong first is that down time where
people are ready to work but no one's
telling them to work no one's telling
them to go there or do that it almost in
some ways feels like babysitting and I
want to like put down other departments
it's not like that but people are
waiting do their jobs if you don't have
a foreman like on a construction site
waiting to tell them okay guys you need
to go in and do this you need to come
out so they can go in and do this then
no one knows what to do is a lot of
people milling around so for me as soon
as we're in soon as that clock hits
seven o'clock or eight o'clock whatever
time your call time is it's immediately
getting every department working on
something
an ideal schedule or an ideal world has
every department constantly working
whether it's on the scene that we're
shooting currently prepping the next
scene wrapping out the previous scene
any elements like that that we can do we
have a B camera that's not shooting
because of the setup in this particular
scene then let's get B camera to go
outside and get b-roll let's get the
house let's get the cars let's get the
sunset let's get something but people
are sitting around doing nothing then
that becomes an issue that should be
rectified in an ideal world watch your
ears real quick nine minutes guys nine
minute warning triage slate it will
sound
call it happy c21 Apple take one camera
camera please market so as a first idea
you're almost never resting well it's
like it sounds like you're you're always
looking at for the next step and doing
two things at once it sounds like yes I
mean as a per se D if you're resting I'm
not sure you're working I just don't
know how that works
look how your bigger budget stuff where
you have a second ad a second second
multiple second seconds a key PA and a
PA when you have all these personnel and
all these resources at your disposal
sure you can step up set relaxed if you
smoke have a cigarette whatever the case
may be but if you're working in the
let's say under 250,000 budget range you
just don't have the personnel underneath
you to support you in that kind of way
and in order to keep the film moving at
a pace that usually again at those
budget levels it needs to move you have
to be on at all times yeah you don't
step off set you step off stuff to 10:1
use the restroom you step up set to 10:1
grab a bottle of water and come back and
theoretically if you've got a PA you
radio them they get you the water
because every second you step off is a
second that someone may not be working
or things may not be moving forward
those seconds add up over the course of
a day and certainly over the course of a
long shoot and what they add up to is
shots you didn't get set up so you
couldn't grab performances that couldn't
be tweaked because you didn't have time
and that time gets lost yes because
other people aren't doing their jobs but
fundamentally because you weren't there
to supervise them and have them continue
to work through that challenges for a
first ad on set and how you work around
it
challenges for a first ad on set and how
to work around it
well that's that's the challenge in of
itself stay into that question each film
set inherently comes with its own
variables and its own issues I'd be very
easy to be like oh well the problems are
X Y Z and this is how you solve them
unfortunately that's not the situation
certainly in this industry but
specifically is the first ad you have to
first and foremost evaluate what
resources are and resources referred to
not only just what you physically have
but your personnel as well do I have
five people or do I have one that's
gonna change how the problems are you're
going to encounter and how you can solve
them ideally you're solving those
problems before you get to them anyways
but maybe not and then obviously the
physical resources of your equipment
money the house what time can we shoot
fighting the daylight if you're outside
all that kind of stuff so in terms of
common problems I mean I think really
the most common problem you're always
going to run into is personality you
know you have people with egos or not
those people who are hard to work with
or easy to work with but they're green
they're not experienced they want to
learn so you have to teach onset as
you're going along it's really
fundamentally it's not about being the
first ad that you think you should be
it's about being the first ad that this
particular production with these
particular people need you to be and I
think that's a problem with a lot of
people who take this position is that
they come in with a very they know the
rules I know the regulations they know
how to do the job but they approach
every job the same and in doing so you
can't fit a square peg into a round hole
you have to be malleable yourself take
those first few days to figure out what
this needs and how to work with people
and if you can do that and adapt quickly
and efficiently then hopefully you
minimize those problems that you're
talking about for you when you first
step on let's suppose you're gonna have
a 17 day shoot at what point do you find
that you get this to this gut level of
like okay I think this is where the
issues are going to be not not specific
people maybe maybe not but like where do
you get the temperament of the set when
does it start to like reveal itself to
you I think by day two I think you're
really paying attention probably really
honestly by lunch on day one because
it's very easy to see okay so he's got a
chip on his shoulder and he doesn't
communicate well and she you know like
you can really kind of get that pretty
quickly but if you haven't figured out
by day two then you're not gonna figure
it out I mean it's just at that point it
should have revealed itself now in a 17
day shoot if you're moving from location
to location maybe new problems arise in
that sense we're okay we're in this
location but this location super strict
they want padding down on the floor they
want layout bore and ran board and they
want this and that and the other so you
have to
discover those problems and then change
and acclimate to them extremely fast
because you don't have the two days
previously to kind of build up to it and
work out a scheme or a plan to make it
work so that's the biggest thing
otherwise yeah I if you're paying
attention if you're on set and you're
working with people and you're listening
and communicating I think you find out
by the end of the first date really no
later than the end of the second I get
the sense that you're really good at
reading people that you just have this
like an eight thing where you can just
figure out what someone needs where they
need to be led am i right with that or
yeah you have a really quick sense with
that I think I think I have a really
quick sense to read people I think it
makes me as valuable and as good at the
job as I am I hope it does I think
without that it becomes much more
difficult to do the job as effectively
as I want to and iodide strive to do it
sure all right let's try one guys
obviously Chuck gets hold control here
to say stop cut whatever the case may be
let's go to one's watch they like watch
the reflections starting from right here
so Frank I think you clear over to this
side just to say that we don't come over
system swinging all over the world all
right let's try it here was going off
pictures up so we're on the set of
deadly reunion and this is day 8 of day
eight of eight eight of eight okay and
you're been in this one location would
have been some of the challenges here at
this location and how have you been
working through it and also the script
changes locations simple enough I mean
you it's a door just point right like
you get challenges and you get benefits
from being in one location the benefits
being no location moves you don't have
to rap out which takes time every time
you do that you're taking time away from
shooting time away from shooting because
we're living here all the gears here
everything's constant it's very easy to
come in at the top of the day you have a
7:00 a.m. call be shooting by 8:00
everything's here and it's you end the
previous day correctly then you can
already be lit pre like aren't decked
and pre blocked and all that for the
following day so you come and you get
right to work so that's the benefits the
problem is you're in one location for a
long time from a aesthetic point direct
totally speaking aesthetically you don't
have a lot of variety in your visual
aesthetic which can more the audience
know if that's the director and me
talking but you get the idea from a
practical standpoint as an ad we're
really on top of each other you know
there's gear here you don't have a lot
of room to
this isn't a mansion it's a house so
it's very congested as a matter of
efficiently having the departments work
around each other
so having grip and electric come in
having them come out and then having art
go in if everyone just tries to cluster
in to do their jobs at the same time you
have a mess and everything goes slower
the way to do it efficiently is to make
sure that certain departments have the
floor at certain times to make it work
in the quickest way possible
now as for scheduling the script changes
so there is a day one rewrite which is
is five if it's a partial rewrite or a
senior write this was a full rewrite of
the script during that was decided to be
done on day one of photography of day
one of shooting so we shot we set
shutdown half day early the rewrite
started so as an ad what becomes
extremely problematic and extremely
challenging is how do I schedule a
restless shoot how do you schedule a
film that you don't know what's about to
take place
theoretically I would have a breakdown I
know everything that goes on in every
scene I know what props I need what
wardrobe changes what special effects
and I have everything blocked out and
certain ways to shoot it again
efficiently in this situation I didn't
have that so the beginning of production
was challenging and stressful I think
for a lot of especially the department
heads in camera grip and Electric in
that usually you'd shoot out all the
scenes in the living room and then all
the scenes in the bathroom and you just
be done with that room and you'd move on
because we were getting pages the
morning of we were pretty much shooting
current and chronological order just
living room to bathroom back to living
room back to here because I never knew
what was coming next and I didn't have
time director didn't have time no one
had time to really break things down and
look at it we just had to grab them and
go what the challenge there becomes is
the morale that's really the challenge
there's no one wants to go back and
we're going back to the living room
again for the same lighting setup that
we just had okay and you just you can
just feel that morale drown and once
that starts to go down you feel the
energy dip when the energy dips
everything moves slower even people are
trying to do their jobs they just don't
have the passion for it so it's really
the passion I'm checking my time sorry
guys five minutes guys five minute
warning
so you're the passion did
and everything move slower you don't get
as much footage in the can you'll get as
much quality out of your personnel what
was nice is that we had already
scheduled a three day break in the
middle of week one and week two so
during that three-day break the
screenwriter who was doing the revisions
was able to get a good chunk of pages
out now that first week what I was doing
was going home seeing what few pages I
had four or five and trying to plant
some kind of game plan whatever it might
be and get something out and that worked
you know to a to a level it worked as
much as it could but now on the last day
of that break I got 15 20 pages so there
it could actually mmm schedule a day or
two ahead and actually group some things
together and block shoot some scenes so
that became much more accessible much
more tackle tackle able able to be
tackled there you go
much more able to be tackled than it had
previously which is where we are now at
this point in unday eight the last three
days have been able to run more like a
legitimately planned set if you will
then flying by the cuff of her pants
like we had been and I understand some
people actors whatever are not aware of
who's dying when and they may be
surprised right well the original script
in the original script nobody really
died per se hmm I characters might left
the scene for a while and the other but
for the most part they'll live through
it one character died toward the end but
everyone's really in the whole thing
during that day one rewrite conversation
it was decided that some of these
characters would die to up the drama up
the tension in doing so everyone's like
yeah we're okay with that but then I
don't think anyone things that they're
gonna be the first to die until they are
and then you're like oh I die in page 15
like I wanna be the movie so that's
that's the situation yeah you know we
had actors coming in looking over the
pages in the morning going holy this is
what happens today or I die today or
whatever it may be and we were doing the
same thing for the most part as well
just reading them and going wow this is
this give me up one day so yeah they
didn't know what's coming the tough part
about that for budgeting time and
structuring things like that is usually
I can look at something and go okay this
is a massive fight team
and maybe it only says it's 1/8 of a
page total on the script but I know it's
gonna be 4 hours of shooting to get it
without having the time to free do that
pre project pre-production work and
really break down the script I'm left
with guessing at how much time certain
things should take strictly based on my
previous experience which is actually
worked out pretty well but also it could
have been a catastrophe